chérie j'aime j'aime pas le casting de
danse avec les stars saison 9
les premières rumeurs on a pris ce
week-end kheris mittenaere donc ex miss
france et miss univers devait participer
à la saison 2 de danse avec les stars
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que des
rumeurs commencent à circuler et on a
les noms de dolci n'est qu'au 3e
l'adorent d'autres gynéco c'est notre
ami il était la semaine dernière
merci si la loi n'a pas été approché à
bien à bien la loi n'a bien ou pas loana
la numismatique filet pourquoi tu étais
tu sors et et pète et pète tout quoi
alors là parce que tu es petit tu peux
pas danser à de dire des conneries il
faut bien mettre un nom sur près de
dieppe et ils apparaîtront pratique
normale un nom tu sors
j'ai rien dis moi madame énorme est
alors minimes at il un message
énigmatique très populaire de la fiction
de tf1 très bon puisqu'elle tourne elle
aurait de toute façon jamais le temps de
le faire tant qu'etat et les cherry on
parle également
alors on parle de dylan oui dis là est
ce que tu vas faire danse avec les stars
dont vous avez fait le casting on
rappeler ou pas ici mais ne ment pas
géré leur faut le j-20 gossuin mail dit
d'arrêter ça mais ça va je pense que des
millions de gens reçoivent des mails non
là on n'a reçu aucun mail non mais dis
la vérité tard chien mais une fois
j'aimerais bien voir bon j'ai eu un
petit mail mais un petit truc il a aussi
négocié négocie ça va être énorme non
27001 et et on parle
ils ont approché coûté bien marion
maréchal-le pen auquel participent à
danse avec les stars
il faut demander à viktor bercy pense
victoire quel est pour vous le à lyon
l'a fait une petite académie politique
oui mais est-ce que vous ce que c'est ça
vous plairait de l'avoir dans bâle
possible oui ça m'intéresserait mais
c'est totalement elle le fera pas mais
en paraît qu'ils ont approché donc elle
a reçu un mail au sous-lieutenant mairie
et les gars il faut partir des mets
groupe est franchement réputé verra bien
tiens mais on voit des matches il n'a
pas reçu de mail preuve
gérard jamais les b merci on vous
donnera tous les jours les nouvelles de
danse avec les stars oui oui alors à
propos d'iris alors iris a effectivement
été contacté pour danse avec les stars
il faut savoir qu iris et rené cros des
roannais
[Rires]
here is a été contacté pour danse avec
les stars effectivement mais il se
trouve que dans angie jaguar york a été
tournée qui sera diffusée faire aux
jardins warriors elle a été tellement
exceptionnelle dixinn buisson le
président de tf1 un qui pense à le
croire elle à l'animation danse avec les
stars
bon moi j'ai fait ninja et elle était
très très fort pour sa première vraie et
bah oui c'est vrai que vous avez fait
ninja warriors ça s'est bien passé
super génial vous avez fini le parcours
bas